welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by audit calm
listen for your supplemental needs audit
is the way to go
whether it's room tech shrimp export
immune whether it's alpha brain the
label of the company because I'll tell
you what
what company tells you if you don't like
their product don't even send it back
we'll just give you a money-back
guarantee and my all-time favorite the
hem force Kakao protein shake 16 grams
of hemp protein per scoop you fill tip
top Magoo after that number two if you
if you take good care yourself you're
gonna need to take a good [ __ ] from now
when you're writing your Christmas list
to sound this year tell that son of a
[ __ ] one thing he still owes your money
and do that you want you has to be the
[ __ ] cleanest [ __ ] ass 1018 to get
you a tissue bidet Jake what's a bidet
oh it's a portable attachment the day
that you strap onto your toilet and say
goodbye the toilet paper it's just
straight up cleans your [ __ ] ass it's
like I go on the carwash
that's go clean the I'm saying if you
imagine that the premium the Bellagio
fountains of Bellagio fountain it your
[ __ ] [ __ ] mainland and you're the
king of your castle in fact for me I'm
saying the king of your throne go -
hello - she calm right now $69 I'm gonna
get you right now press in church and
get 10% off your order
number three again you're making
resolutions you got immediately good G
this year
Fuji Sports is the way to go I'm an a
six now I'm down on a five people tug on
it they pull on it they can't [ __ ]
rip it I love it if you're a fat [ __ ]
and either G Agee go over the Fuji
splits time right now get the super ATO
or get the basic white the lightweight
you're gonna [ __ ] love it go to the
window and press in church and get 10%
off is that easier right so I gave you
Fuji I gave you hello
she and I gave you audit dr. Lee get
this [ __ ] party started
that is a [ __ ] Jam damn it happy
Monday you bad [ __ ]
it's December the rent is due Christmas
is do New Year's is do your resolution
just [ __ ] do so start thinking about
them
my main [ __ ] professor Joey Alvarado
am I going to come back yeah yeah the
king of cattle Jitsu right what the [ __ ]
cattle Jitsu is now you know you're I'm
saying and my main [ __ ] goombah
Lee sciatica the [ __ ] savage of the
[ __ ] didn't someone get a no
right killer thing Christ killer how do
you get a moniker like that guy's kill
it
I got the old-school Italians are called
Jews [ __ ] [ __ ] that's a you
hear somebody say in Italian huh it's
[ __ ] hilarious see like in the it
sounds an angry it sounds like what
Hitler would say see now Gaston kick
kick when it Martin it doesn't know my
faster Greek they say really stop
killing or something I had to say it
once for an audition for a Boardwalk
Empire yeah I was playing sound Manzano
and that's when I first had heard it
before great skill I was like hail
that's a bit [ __ ] static either yeah
Jewish people but in the for these 30s
and 50s that's what they [ __ ] call
them know you're on that Boardwalk
Empire
no they sent me an additionally two or
three times I couldn't I watched the
episode I was pretty klutz a [ __ ]
great you know crazy ass craziest
[ __ ] show that Buscemi guy Buscemi it
was you know right there around the time
with The Sopranos HBO was on fire mm-hmm
what's going on professor you know same
old same old man just hustling getting
ready for a big tournament this month
tired sore but you know I'm just always
grinding around teaching I teach that's
what I do what I love fortunate to do it
for a living
yeah but you do it like crazy time so
it's not like you're rolling in there
ten o'clock in the morning yeah yeah you
know but um like when I start off like I
wake up Monday Wednesday Friday I wake
up at 4:00 a.m. and I do the five to
rethink
but like right all right I teach a 5:30
a.m. a 6:30 a.m. and then I crash out on
the couch for a little while so I take I
take little naps you know but I mean on
average I teach little over 20 classes a
week so I really only worked 20 hours a
week because each class is an hour but
it's not that grueling you know they get
used to I'm used to that schedule you
know they have a lot of classes that
they do they really [ __ ] do so 6:30
twelve six thirty seven thirty eight
thirty now you're missing it goes well
yeah that's just like jiu-jitsu and
stuff like yeah that's five classes a
day four days a week then you skip my
eyes my 10:00 a.m. - so like that's how
they am no Gihon money whoa what was
that and then we still got on Friday we
got another class there at 6:30 yes
there's no two classes and then you got
one on Saturday mm-hmm and two on Sunday
really right well for jujitsu [ __ ]
together masters right the Masters well
the Masters training is kind of like
that's off the that's off the record
right there it's not you know that's
that's just for like them a bunch of old
guys yeah the cat cats they don't want
to like no no they just wanted to train
with each other you know like was like a
safer environment yeah yeah you got to
be a certain age so if you don't have a
certain age man and you sneak in there
they'll kick you out they are you know I
mean because like I mean I'm 46 years
old man in I mean I'll roll with all the
young cats and stuff like that but man
you know I could see how it takes its
toll on people's body man you know like
some of the older cats just they can't
do it but everybody's built up
differently you know I got the blood of
a fire in me so maybe that's why I'm
able to hang with these young cats but
sometimes men like these young cats roll
with these older guys and they're just
young and and and spasm spazzy too you
know and make it a man I catch a little
stuff and they don't and they don't want
they don't want to roll like that all
the time you know I mean and some people
just don't have control in in the
master's class they want to keep it fun
and and safe and you know just kind of
like nothing to create so I'm so sore I
think it starts I think it's like a
eight o'clock on Sundays and you don't
even wall
as one of those like no [ __ ] around
classes to bring you at 7:00 in the
morning doesn't really heard that it's
like [ __ ] old dudes yeah yeah yeah
that's alright you know it's cool when
you you can cater to like groups like
that you know because like over here I
was just talking to a guy not a lot of
gyms have a good female program and and
we have a really good female program
over at Legacy you know and then they
have like a 9:00 a.m. on Saturdays they
have a just all-female class was just
all girls you know and that's good to
have that Matt because you know like
these girls I mean they're they're all
most of them have to roll with guys all
the time and it's [ __ ] hard man it's
hard for a little bit I have this local
free all man let me a Mexican girl I was
my all-time favorite and asking her that
went to work at South's and chips
oh she signed up and like eat that Blanc
eat that like you did I had money that
monkey that could kill him [ __ ]
did she was like she is so so she's like
I think she was like for ya heart of
gold
sweetheart yeah but the immigrant
mentality you know she's hot as [ __ ]
she's strong and she's flying and
sometimes you roll with a woman and they
take you for a loop and you're like yeah
yeah yeah sure sure
at first I was [ __ ] around so you got
that crazy string yeah that some women
that's just and you get impressed with
you're like okay yeah for sure man so
she's a scrappy little girl man
you know like sometimes those little
people are though you know I mean you
get little people they get that Napoleon
complex so they they they're always
being picked on and stuff like that so
they're like naturally like scrappy man
you know I mean we have a few little
scrappy people at our gym that are Benny
know Benny yeah that's better he's
definitely little Benny Blanco from the
Bronx Blanco from the Bronx hey boss
sweetest kid in the world yeah ain't
gonna catch him because he just keeps
moving you chased him he just stopped by
the window next thing you know buddy I'm
trying to grab the back of his pants and
he's pushing away from me I'm like he's
like you're not getting on top of me up
the hill I don't give a [ __ ] what it
takes and every time I'm there I always
go roll and then come get me because
he actually wants to get away from me he
knows after midnight uh michael enough
okay I'm chasing yeah but that's his
[ __ ] strategy that's his game that is
his game it'll try the gone barmy and
he'll push away father do your cartwheel
right oh yeah over you cartwheels only
does everything yeah they wait one
[ __ ] forty these guys they're not
gonna let you are they got my knee
he's kicking at my hips he don't get mad
them because if that happens him on the
street and he's my teammate he's my
brother I wanted him to be prepared and
you know it's when you look at me and
you see think all this guy's gonna get
on top of me when I see those guys I
applaud him even meanwhile as soon as I
land in the side control
I always go up a little bit and I ask
them how are we doing down there
breathe that's because you have a
[ __ ] crazy I'm so then and breathe
sometimes they just sweep me these
[ __ ] not my kind of place with
you all the time that's my main sweep
aka joke that's my street name well I
could and they play me now they learn
how to Marco I can't get on Marco yeah I
can't stay on Marco from morning Marco
blame me
Michael plays me perfectly and he'll
work a lot Marco hard but that's what's
gotten working so hard because if he
knows in his mind that if he could get
me off him after a minute and I lay that
his stomach I [ __ ] with him a little bit
I make believe I'm gonna come or I'm
doing nothing just laying on his stomach
so you're giving us your strategy out
right now
I got one strategy fat professor came up
to me cuz I don't know if I ever told
you this he goes when I was in Brazil
that was his dude you know and he had a
little belly he submitted everybody
bypass and they caught and then getting
them north-south okay yeah but my hand
doesn't go under to get that my wrist
was what wrist just put your stomach on
their face because
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
Brazilian do you know did you know Laval
yes what about okay I haven't seen him
so long moved to Texas okay well anyway
like at one point he was really big oh
yeah yeah that's a surgery and I've seen
him after that but anyway he was [ __ ]
funny as [ __ ] like he was my student man
and he was to say he was in the same
predicament as you but like he's bigger
than you he's so much bigger but he
learned he developed his own submission
to it was called the titty tap so he
would [ __ ] get the side mount and
he'd [ __ ] put his titty on top of him
and smother him and they [ __ ] this
get suffocated tap out you can't like it
lapel was that he go go that that's a
titty tap [ __ ] fell out okay no kid
from Jersey I love it that school with
all my heart is damaged better ready
oh yeah there's a little belly and then
there's big man yeah yeah big Benny
Benihana
I love Big Ben and big Betty came up to
and then Big Ben he went to Brazil and
[ __ ] a bunch of people up in the
Philippines and killer Philippines and
he came back and the Philippines he's
always in class and he works hard he's
like dog I don't know how long you
wouldn't know it sounds he goes that's
the only time I ever panicked that day
man you know like when you had me in
North South and your chest was on me
Joey I really started to panic
I almost time yeah and that and then
that's a bit I was I was totally [ __ ]
thinking the same thing whenever you had
me inside mount the other day and I was
like if I didn't know how to position my
hands and breathe properly somebody
would just be freaking out under this
guy man cuz he you gotta distribute your
weight really well when you're inside
mount you know I'm Todd yeah yeah you're
not trying to give anything up dude oh
no no no
it's it's a thinking man's game I'm
waiting for you and what experience
everybody you know everybody's more
experienced I am so there they've
already experienced to wait it out wait
till Joey throws his leg over those two
knee on belly will get them sometimes I
fake in the arm Valley and go the other
way and that adds that extra weight well
I stopped doing that you taught me in
the beginning that I stopped by a man
that was the mount the mount if I'd
loved mountain and I'd like to see him
buck three or four I'm not even
submission them I just let them burn on
their own oh you just say back that I
move my knees up and I get them with a
choke and then I stop doing
I just thought one day that I don't like
mountain yeah you know it's so it's so
weird but the thing that I'm the most
about jujitsu is it teaches you who the
[ __ ] you are a fisherman in the simplest
way it's a mirror with an x-ray machine
that really teaches you every [ __ ]
one of your insecurities your weaknesses
and then you have to figure out how to
overcome all that [ __ ] yeah that's why
all those small guys Baca that little
there's a little a little New York
looking brown belt that comes in during
the week stocky dude all those dudes
they [ __ ] yeah don't give a [ __ ] of
their five for once my head goes over a
certain angle I know I'm going
night-night yeah I know they're sending
me for a loop I know it in their
experience yeah yeah yeah always has me
sure sure sure
very interesting what I've learned the
last couple movies but I also learned
that at my age I have to be doing some
type of weight work every week yeah I
could roll twice a week at that rate for
me yeah for sure and that's why I've
always looked at your programs I mix
them I got a couple of those little
Albert old bat's huh
and I'm loosening up with that and I'll
do cleans huh and last week I totally
last Sunday was the first time cuz I
miss him listen playing football
if you can't tackle sucks dick alright
the reason why you play football is a
tackle [ __ ]
chase somebody down and tackle them and
get them down or block them thing doing
a kettlebell workout and not doing
swings sucks dick yeah yeah I mean like
the thing is is I mean you can mix it up
if you know your now I know how to mix
it up I know that after I do swings I
can't sit down the right Tommy yeah that
was the other thing you can get to whine
about tightens your back too much huh
yeah and then when you're on the
computer you're basically it's unnormal
cuz your heads down throwing away your
neck cracking yourself I didn't know
this for this last time I hurt my back
cuz that you know when you write the
thing about writing is just like jujitsu
that's why I compare both arts I like
these people who I write one hour a day
that's good professor joy but it's not
gonna work because you don't find new
jujitsu the same way like you don't find
your writing so you're frustrated so
this two and a half hour and second
fight come over to your house
I keep passing your guard and keep mine
on topic okay you know when you're gonna
figure out when the two-and-a-half hour
mark yeah you're gonna learn oh wait a
second look at this and then you know go
let's do this again and then you're
gonna get me from the other side yet
writing is the same way you'll sit there
with a pen doing this [ __ ] so I stopped
doing that now now I actually take a
story and go yesterday professor Joey
taught me how to do the omoplata I
kicked my legs and while I'm writing
that I'll go home apply for that's a
funny word yeah so you follow me but it
don't happen in an hour that's one of
people go to me home I write an hour a
day
that's not nice you wanna be serious no
no no that's not nothing you want to
work on your game so the game gets
delivered at the end of run and there's
days professor will you be able to do
ten o'clock class the 11 o'clock you'll
do 10 o'clock
nogi 11 o'clock drill and 12 o'clock
Alberto class and you're still not gonna
get it but there's gonna be days that
you're gonna get it by and that's the
same thing of writing yeah so sometimes
I may be sitting there to the
of that and lost that the tool a half
mark and next thing you know I've been
sitting there I left our burrows at 1:30
I went home had a protein shake and I've
been sitting then it's [ __ ] 6:45
professor when you will go to get up you
have no idea what your body feels like
at 45
yeah yeah yeah yeah if you do ten sets
of swings in ten minutes and three sets
of cleans and three sets of goblets and
then I would do three sets of one-armed
swings I can't sit down after that you
have to be and then I dolphins are not
kicking in I do the stretch or so I'm
gonna do the warm down go down the cool
down I do everything the thighs and now
what I've been doing that works oh my
god professor you ready I'm gonna drop
the bomb on you because I know I saw you
[ __ ] with it somebody's [ __ ] with
it at Alberto's they had the bomb that I
have the bomb did CBD bomb no no no you
going to shower you put the shower on
real hot you take the deodorizer soap
huh and you wash down and then you take
the loofah and you do the regular soap
see some little oh boy you don't smell
like you you got the hip you know I'm
saying and then you [ __ ] put shampoo
in there and you come out and before you
try yourself down you go to the wheat
store and you buy the DVD CBD oil huh
and you rub it on your [ __ ] legs like
cream profess them the next morning you
wake up is that all you're a professor
you can't rub it on your dick that's a
little bengay effect you want to get
your dick tiresome dog once you start
getting up there in age you need
everything you can to go to the gym the
next day yeah man I love that CBD [ __ ] I
like CB these [ __ ] lately I get you
gotta try this stuff that I use man not
the roll-on I guess all the role on the
role on I love it but the robot is the
[ __ ] I've used I went through it I went
through what are you using the one you
use it then licks it here I've made I
may believe like I did you see
did you leave that for me somebody it
was there somebody left it for me and I
was like I was like oh my god I got a
hat on my store I got it from Gino at
speed weed that's really that's who's
got it okay speed we do
that's the neck secure please so much
secure guys here you it's a roll on like
so I love it you go home and you take a
shower I would put it on my knee before
the ice and then I would put the ice on
my knee take it off you know what I do
man like and for my knees to it like
it's crazy because I roll it on before
training and I'll put my knee brace over
it so now like that knee brace has has
that [ __ ] in it so now I'll put me brace
under without it and then I take it off
and it's all cool again unless I love
that [ __ ] man so that it really cools
cools your spazzy muscles down like man
I'm always like rubbing it on my knee
when I get in okay when I walk in the
door just a moment my bag I put on the
counter I take the gear out the [ __ ]
the trash cart I throw in the laundry
and the lunch it just happens to be
there's a door and I open up the other
door I take a nice back and I put it on
my back huh okay then I get a big glass
of whatever water I have left I take two
Tylenol I drink them then I go right to
my computer I return the emails but I
also write the technique of the day that
you talk now and how I did if I rolled
and who how long I last I just wrap so I
know exactly you take it a little
journal yeah so you have 90 minutes with
that ice on your back you follow me that
ass is on my butt man you know like
people don't use ice and um no I don't
realize I learned like a phony grace man
you don't let your knees at night like
oh why would I I'm just a fat [ __ ] he
goes even more yeah an even more he was
ice your knees twice three times a week
when 24 sure 20 minutes see if you have
sore muscle like oh yeah please shreds
up preventative because I'm young what I
don't
why not and then you take the [ __ ]
ice pack well it's such a cool down and
your legs are elevated and you scrub
them down your [ __ ] front of your
legs like a savage shoe you rub them
down it's like a ritual party dry is
your question and you're a healthy guy
oh yeah healthy I think what does the
day of Joey Alvarado consists of only
wakes up before the more than a damn
I've always told people this what does
it take to be Joey Alvarado to wake up
before to get and do care about and
you're not just there with a whistle
acting like Larry Bird technique with
Dahle yeah a train with mice and then
alley by the time you go into [ __ ]
whatever goodbyes and hugs you put that
la bamba music on that [ __ ] bus music
in mind then then you you put a gear on
and then you start doing tumbles you're
46 year old man now it's two hours
already in you take that nap without
that I know you drink a lot of water I
know you taking supplements you know
maybe maybe not I know you may be taking
a protein gel of a drug okay now you
know man
man just because I I do what I love for
a living so like the kettlebell stuff is
I love that people actually show up to a
5:30 a.m. class right they get [ __ ]
crazy like to do something that I
develop and I would have a heart attack
you know that cattle bones but yet now
you wouldn't men always tell people just
to go at your own pace man you know I
know how to push into classes like if
you're in it orally or somebody was to
show up and they didn't never did my
workout then I'm not gonna like make you
do every little bit I'm like dude take a
break use a lighter weight you know
practice technique more than anything
because I mean your average person can't
go through an hour class like me I mean
people do that all the time your class
in an hour
it's an hour oh my god so long but but
no that's the thing that's the
misconception it's not just kettlebell
okay bodyweight and kettlebells so we
start looking already doing mobility
right there we start off with mobility
right there then we do a core warmup we
do an ab workout then we do a bodyweight
workout and then we
to the kettlebell stuff you know I just
posted a video on Instagram it kind of
like takes you through the protocols of
one of my workouts it's nothing yeah an
hour of ketab straight kettlebell would
just be freaking crazy
oh my god I would probably die what's
your Instagram handle Jitsu just look up
kettle jitsu yeah I looked at all your
videos because like I said I don't want
to be Joe atlas but I want to be a
little strong we're gonna keep your
muscles strong and safe you want to
prevent osteoporosis yeah for sure you
got to keep moving man when you stop
moving that's when your body starts
seizing up on you you know
kettlebells are the biggest fat burner
besides swimming which have to do I have
to put it you not to do a surgery for
one day I have put a tube in my ear cuz
after jujitsu that fluid all stays in my
and I go deaf and I can't okay
it's bad enough like I don't tell people
this [ __ ] I don't know what you're
saying sometimes huh huh that's why I
gotta do you ever seen me looking at you
yeah yeah yeah yeah 22 hours why is Joey
they're gonna be like that cuz I gotta
read your lips and listen plus you blow
my mind you're blowing my mind is the
funniest like like if I teach it it
could be like the littlest thing and
then his eyes light up like a little kid
he just gets of look your eyes we got a
little kitty I love it I love it so I
have to pay that much attention to him
people have music that like relates to
kickbox it was the perfect size Jim to
make me to give me anxiety from the
music mmm it was just a it was taken ten
feet away from our boroughs with that
same length if you put music on too loud
with Yui talking I get vertigo outside
you're there it's too much it's too much
our boroughs it's perfect I have to
really look at you like when I'm looking
at you during the class as cuz Dawg I'm
really playing it anyway I'm looking at
your lips yeah you're very attentive
student I can't hear I can't hear ya so
I have to play have to focus even more
when you read lips yeah why came from
you got a reason this part-time lips oh
my god I was a part-time everything I
totally a day for years I didn't know
lip reader was an occupation when I was
eight
I found a Chanel lip not by mistake the
true relative of mine was a tremendous
pickpocket
that was another one of your professions
to pickpocketing oh my god when I was a
young young kid at the a July 6 I heard
rumors about a relative of mine that was
just superb superb enough that are some
beat cop could be standing in the corner
and that is the highest honor of a big
pop is to take the badge off a couple
nice honored I saw so that's the
equivalent of like getting being a
bright stripes and yeah you know
pickpocketing pocket is to go up to a
cop and take the badge off and then go
back up to him ten minutes and put it
back up no that's a lot that's how and
are like movie [ __ ] listen to me there's
a movie call about pickpockets that
you'll never even find it was a movie
they made one well they made focus with
whatever the [ __ ] it is Will Smith with
the hot chick that was great that was
about pickpocketing pickpocketing scams
you know when there's an event in the
city what really happens okay when an
event goes down in Houston like you
think it's a Super Bowl but every scam
in the country is headed down there
every hooker yeah yeah because that's
where the money is that you know yeah so
Wow but Harry in your pocket is like it
could be James Coburn and it's an old
movie
see what year it is Harry in your pocket
Harry in your pocket it's about these
dudes that that's it they work that boys
that's when you gonna have money on you
so that movie came out and me hearing
all this [ __ ] about pickpocketing so I
asked one of my relatives 73 I asked one
of my hoes in the movie
what scene I asked one of my relatives
from Cuba how do you become a pickpocket
he goes that whole side of the family I
thought this is your movie by the way
that holds who's in the movie James
Coburn moja Michael Sampson yeah I
treasure ben de Vere yeah yeah twister
doing Walter Pidgeon yeah this move this
these movies they don't even make movies
like this no things Coburn I know so I
asked around that side of the family
they said that oh my
they were they had houses set up with
dummies with clothes on and wallets but
they have belts and that's how you
trained to become a pig pot right I got
I got pickpocket training center like my
family's like that son looks like I'm a
pickpocket dojo screaming there's a
pickpocket dojo have you seen the videos
from the Olympics in Brazil with the
pickpockets I could just imagine it was
it was it's brilliant if they were
really an art it was following them and
they knew they were do have that's why I
hate touristy areas that's why I hate
tourists and that's why though I don't
hate tourists I feel bad for tourists
who make it obvious that they're
tourists right because there are people
that prayer like when I lived in San
Francisco in 85 I prayed on tourists
mm-hmm I would sit there reading the Los
Angeles the the the San Francisco times
with a suit on with to a long pair of
shoes on and when Joe Alvarado would
check in hi Joe Alvarado would you like
to use American Express no cash I know I
got a pigeon well in room 312 in those
days that's why they write it down now
to you and give it to you oh my god
because there'd be guys like me in the
hallway reading her lips going through
the room 312 and I just sit there what's
the first thing you do when you get to a
city you drop your [ __ ] off and you're
going on comma and I would shoot right -
you won't kick the door down and take
whatever I had to take that's how you
make a living in those days Wow or I'd
have the key to the room and in those
days I had them I would rent the room in
the hotel and just there was no cameras
in the eighties so I would rent the room
in the hotel I wake up in the morning
and follow the maid and wait till she
lose a lot of maids in those days would
leave the keys in the door huh they're
in there [ __ ] talking to the other
maids in Spanish I take the master gate
go sometimes I make a copy and put it
back and throw in the hallway but I'd
have a master key oh my god and man how
long would it take for the man in shape
to change the key two or three days but
oh my god yeah by that
I had half the building done that's
crazy
crazy [ __ ] no this is just where I lived
this is why I wasn't Wow gangsta do you
ever wish that you weren't on like like
addicted to cocaine because you could be
like living in like the Virgin Island or
something I'm like a like a secret
island now if you had all the stuff that
you at that time it wasn't even the
addiction to cocaine that time it was
just the high that was a high for me
right to go out in the daytime with two
dollars in your pocket and come home
with 800 yeah you get it I mean that's
it's an adrenaline where did the money
go
I go to [ __ ] Morton's oh my god
tonight if the lame please your this way
I was a type of dude that today if I
woke up this morning with 7 bucks and I
went to what's popular all right
Christmas this is this is this was my
time of the year this is I'm getting
paid because hey all I gotta do now is
walk into target or a big store go look
for a blanket the biggest size blanket
you can't do this today take it go up to
the counter and go hi my mother got me
this yesterday but I already got it
you have to receive no she lost it one
thing I do with this lady
oh yeah I know I you want cash yeah so
awesome book 2064 hours well know who
women are really good at that so I got
264 oh my god yeah oh yeah so now yeah
but not anymore cuz they have a computer
up at your license mmm so once this time
I came on once they started pulling my
license in there I was trying to hit him
nationwide any time I was broke doing
comedy I just walked into a camera they
[ __ ] play have a [ __ ] uh pick up a
thing of Matt Matt's for your car they'd
be 40 bucks then I was just trying to
get rich I just wanted a subway saying
with his shoulder the 20-hour bag of
weed that's it that's that's how
remember in the beginning is trying to
start your day off yeah once you get
your day started now we can negotiate a
little bit I got a hundred what do you
need anything
listen give me a hundred I'll cut you in
partners boom that's real grandma cut of
it now we got a half a gram a coke plus
we got lots of cash and we just bumped
into Lee he wants to buy it out so we
will sell right now I'm selling 3/4 of
an ounce and we'll spray we'll get a
spray bottle and we'll spray we water
into the weed to make it heavy that's
the one he gets it it's flat four ounces
and takes it home the next morning it's
three and a half like it was all day did
you guys ever do yeah you made the weed
wet to make it you felt like you're
making your weather yeah that's crazy
you should spray the weed is the big bag
shake it up and then put it into it then
he did like a little and when you went
to weigh it you're the winners as a [ __ ]
chello dog this is when your
twenty-four-seven made you're hustling
you do like a little guide on how to be
a thug but you can't do this no more
because I still just for sharing they
got careless they got so many they're
yeah man you know that's how you lose
all right so let's pretend like one day
one in 1993 I was just getting into
commie I was into it
but I wasn't getting a job professor and
I was not gonna get a job so what I
decided to do what was the hottest thing
in 1993 coffee machines okay everybody
wanted a coffee machine now if it had an
expresso machine model dummy but if it
had an expresso cappuccino machine and
they have like one that has a wrestle
bar that had a over $400 coffee machine
for a coffee and then the cheaper one
after that was 249 so I always had a
backup stop-and-go hub again I shared a
shave and I would pick it up bring it to
the counter my mother got me this for
Christmas
I already got mechanized machine I don't
even drink coffee how would you like
your money back cash or a check I said
I'll take cash you know you make believe
what you don't want and then they
give you then you go I go okay let's say
I live in LA so I would not I would not
Holly with the one and then I take a
ride to Culver City and to go to the
same store in Culver City and do it all
over now I got nine on your BAM with
Alma do so it's for Connor that neither
the Bucks do I keep stealing no I made
my nut for the day nine hundred I'm good
so what do i do on the way home I
stopped at the weed store I drop a
yardstick I go by the coke dealers house
I drop a yardstick on him I go home I
give mom a deuce because god forbid she
don't got a taste of the action
she doesn't even actually how you made
the money and then you celebrate what do
you wanna do you wanna hold on to it
what are you gonna hold on to but yeah
I'm gonna hold on I'm gonna put it in
the bank no you make reservations at
rails and you walk in there like you own
the joint give them a twenty give them a
20 even though you got ten dollars in
your pocket and guess what you do the
next morning you wake up early and you
do it all over again
you have no idea was a hustle man it's
when I was in Vegas this last week there
are people doing three-card Monte next
to the Bellagio and there were they had
they had a I like a summer girl who
looked like she was smoking crack at the
time as like the the plant to keep
winning that's how people lose hundreds
hundreds because the starting bid was a
hundred hmm it was crazy
how long it take for the cops to get
they had if they had they have like six
TV trays a bit like what the fountain
was they had like six TV TV trays had
people on each one and they had guys up
and down the ship looking and I can't
everyone so every few minutes they take
it off and be like no we will be right
back we'll be right back and they were
there I stood there for like minute so
the Hustle is basically this the Hustle
is you don't three-card Monte it's not
as Monte it was it was a ball under a
cap a ball under can could be that it
could be the you know all under the beam
again go look at it but when I grew up
around was a deck of cards so you take
three cards three ace of spades and you
fold them and I go pick the red one so I
take two black cards in the random two
black cards and
I show it to you joy Alvarado I put the
[ __ ] thing down and all sending you
like no I don't wanna bet Leo come up
and go twenty on the red leaves or one
at twenty hours let's do it yeah we'll
come in again no these ibly works right
and I know Leo but you're a tourist you
just coming in from Belgium yeah this is
counts of three Mexicans there's a
couple Irish yeah we're having a good
time here look at the red look at the
red look at the red Bob boom he knows
where it is again he doubles his money
now now he doubles it again in fact I
even curse them get the [ __ ] outta you
fat you [ __ ] you try to [ __ ] my
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you [ __ ] all nice killer
and all of a sudden it's like magic once
he don't pick your pick and then I get
you for twenty than this guy I'll start
picking and all of a sudden with Jedi
mind trick I swear they do something
when the when the tourist is doing it
because I know where professor within
six minutes I got even 900 Allah and all
of a sudden you who works for me all
forego police even if the cops ain't
coming you just broke up the action and
the energy that tourist who was gonna go
to Disneyland with his kids just got
take afraid huh
there's no I got taken 400 I want to try
it I wanted to try cuz I knew where it
was and they did something and I said I
take my hundred bucks is like [ __ ] you
man really
and he and their brilliant they were
like stay I'm gonna give you a chance to
get your money back man I'm like [ __ ] no
I'm gonna go yeah they're brilliant it's
a scam that's been in New York for
thousands of years and then they would
come and it's all played on a cardboard
box so you ever see cat food whatever
they cup the thing and that clockwork
box they're playing on that three cards
let's go G and it's every 20 minutes a
sack I'm anywhere from eight to eleven
hundred hours and they break it up and
20 minutes later they pop from somewhere
else and 20 minutes a bit all in the
same area and they keep getting the
tourists and it's all day
and then they go you know it's it's
living that life it's a heartless people
do it and die in jail you know because I
want along the line you eventually
knowing to get popped
yeah but you know that was my deterrent
always that these guys even mob guys all
these guys do climbs and all their life
they have a great time to get their
dicks out but then you go to jail when
you're 55 [ __ ] much I don't think that
that's successful nah by no means no nor
the L in 55 your golden years I never
want this is your years where your [ __ ]
you're supposed to be getting checks in
the mail and gonna get a haircut and go
to the park James a drive to training
jiu-jitsu you're an old guy like savage
and whatever I can't imagine going to
jail and you're 55 oh it's 60 70 dying a
[ __ ] jannah now [ __ ] you all those
years for nothing
yeah something you gave it up Joey I'm
glad you did man I had no choice
professor I had no choice because I knew
well the company wouldn't know worked I
knew I would go back to drug dealing
again a bullet I always knew that I used
to shave this doesn't work if something
happens and I have to leave LA why even
do this I just go back to New York move
into a cave sell coke somewhere until
they shoot me I die
what a [ __ ] attitude but who gives a
[ __ ] yeah you know you gotta have
something to fall back on the rice it's
real friend of mine today I spoke to a
friend of mine this morning early he
called me I went outside to smoke pot I
got about 6:30 in the morning had some
coffee and when I came and he had missed
call me and he called me and I called
him back his name is Carlos and I grew
up with his younger brother Dede and my
mother died I hung out tight with them
tight tight and they took care of me you
know those people just they didn't have
much but they and what sad absence all
those was the oldest and Dede was three
years younger than me
bitch-slap and mother
I used to call him manchild manchild
because by the time he had beat up child
he beat up Charlie gives his brother in
such a bad way at that time he was 14
and Charlie gives his brother was 19
play through such a beating on him and
it ended with him taking it and I don't
know if you remember 1980 car bumpers
when that five-mile-an-hour bumpers
bumpers were made of [ __ ] steel
and how that fight ended was didi
grabbing gutta
Gizzi by the head and hitting him
against the car bumper that's unheard of
right away people got aware of him and I
snatched him up early because that's
security there that dude
it became my brother he became my
brother child and all or and then Carlos
was his older brother good-looking guy
and me and Dean II used to get quaaludes
like in high school we were kids and we
buy a quaint little piece for 4 bucks
and we'd split a bottle of vodka and
we'd sit in his room his brother's room
till 2:30 3:00 in the morning [ __ ] up
on the vodka Michaela now I can listen
to Led Zeppelin 3 right and then his
brother would come home and his brother
go what the [ __ ] you guys doing well he
wasn't coming getting a lot of coke for
me he would go I'll give you one lamb to
Danielle leave and he would give us one
little title and a coke and that was it
that was our night so I finally not I
grew up with them I love them but we he
called me they asked me he goes do you
remember a night where you with my
brother there's something happened and
we had a and I go to Jesus Christ I know
I can't believe you're telling me the
story I was just telling my wife had
there because his brother was tough
Carlos always tough and the people
yelling out with what tough and when I
meet deedie is her mother doing her part
my own business and just minding your
own business with a [ __ ] case of beer
and you're smoking pot and there was a
fence like the one we have here mm-hmm
and something happened that girl a girl
but we've grew up with and Dede got into
a conversation but what we didn't know
that up the [ __ ] corner
that's the 16 year old girl the 17-year
girl had like a 20 year old boyfriend we
had no [ __ ] idea what was going on so
the boyfriend comes down it's like
Friday maybe 11 o'clock I got a couple
beers of me a couple lines of coke the
other guys a little tuned up when I know
be these two him Doug now it's the dead
of the winter coq10 carrot there was no
cops dead and none so DV had gone out
with I don't know if you remember this
called Europe via old to remember this
and the 80s a straight football shirts
weight that were covered up to here was
cotton and all on your shoulder but
under here was netting oh yeah yeah it
was 40 degrees he went out with the net
ahead no t-shirt that's how crazy didi
was so if I was 17 Dini was 15 my mother
had already died and something happens
that [ __ ] I'll never forget this dee
dee and the girl look he was
good-looking bro he coulda stole it the
boyfriend came started talking to dee
dee the boyfriends buddies came we all
went up and they threw a beatin on us
but they threw a beating on dee dee they
got punched in the face twice and DB
goes tell ya it was I'm coming back you
guys are [ __ ] his name was Monahan
he just were coming back [ __ ]
and we walked up the hill pissed off his
shirt was ripped and now it's 40 degrees
I'm bleeding from my [ __ ] nose we get
the top and a [ __ ] corner and we see
his brother in a car with three gorillas
who are just eating like a quaalude and
those days there were these brothers
called the Lopez brothers and their
mother was dying to cancer hey and their
mother would get pills
in the first of the month f-16
they don't even make them no more see if
they make them anymore - littles don't
see you am I
and you LS - lost then King citizens so
uh tumor loss - I said - and all to my
no to my goal no I'd search for them
yeah the only make him no more they had
the number on them was
f-16 I'm saying if you got a pill on it
with f-16 little capsule and they were
worth there were three steps worse than
quaaludes they were on those things
Wow and they pulled over them what like
that what happened we go we've just got
into a fight
these dudes breathe this up he goes who
beat you up and we go they're down there
right now and they go run behind this
probably these four guys got out of the
car and they threw a beat on those boots
but the dude who would be obedient
gotten away that was the big thing we
chased him down flavorful so then he
that got like a wheel a that actually
how about this story I heard it like
from Carlos Monaghan the kids would hit
didi was tough like this was no [ __ ]
joke this was gonna become bad because
Carlos even said he goes I thought he
could take me but he was my little
brother I just couldn't let him hit my
little brother tried to confront them so
he was it - dude the first do that would
did heroin with I was about 16 his name
was gonna gut the brown if he asked me
again I'm not get down his name was
Gunther Brown he was old they live the
guitar player from Black Sabbath Tony
Hale any time like that yeah he started
good but his family can't make a good
movie by the way Joey no he came from
where he came from a [ __ ] met money
family and I like Tony Iommi he look
like Tony Iommi and he loved the Beatles
so he had everything listen professor
you know in the 70s everything was
everything was copacetic till they shot
John Lennon and those [ __ ] run away I
love Beatle fans but you were you were
annoying for years and you can pay and
everything to the [ __ ] Beatles then
when Jonalyn and got shot they went away
like [ __ ] herpes they just went away
that's it you see this is a beautiful
friend sawfish I was the end of
Beatlemania yeah that was the answer
Beatlemania but in 1981 that
[ __ ] done to brown you think of
anything Beatle professor he had it
lunchbox beetle fork a Beatle bib
or his house was alarmed to the Gaels
there was no thief he knew where he
lived dog
this guy knew I live close by he knew he
had lights in the living room he had
[ __ ] fences there was no way you
could steal none of his [ __ ] Beatle
memorabilia anyway that that's nothing
to do with it
did he try no no no no no I don't like
the content of the gutter and Carlos saw
him on the hand with a basketball and
Dede was in the car and they pulled over
and had two choices call us and you've
got two choices Edie either I can go
find them or or you'd go find and Dede
goes whatever you want to do cause was
[ __ ] let me go find them so they got
a car the Gunther and Carlos and Edie
and Carlos went up to him like his
mother had what the [ __ ] happened last
night my brother's [ __ ] 15 why did
you why would you do you're a [ __ ]
man you're 20 what the [ __ ] is your
problem
you listen now we have a promise tonight
you and me got a fight and he goes as I
was uttering those words stand
he was coax I was petrified but there he
was I just had to say it to him and the
guy put the basketball down he goes whoa
whoa he goes I don't know where your
brother told you but hold on one second
cuz that's how [ __ ] up we were on the
pills he took off his shirt the kid and
I'll never forget that this side was
just purple it was just purple and he
goes I don't know what your brother told
you but yeah I busted your lip but I
can't even raise my right arm today he
goes you [ __ ] me up yesterday and call
us go to TV what do you wanna do do you
wanna find them or do you want me to
fight them one last shot and the guys
like whoever I fight you're gonna both
beat me up because I can't move my
[ __ ] body I didn't remember that so
like so I don't understand deedy
actually beat his ass but yeah we don't
[ __ ] up he thought he yeah all of us
all of us got beat up I thought I got
beat up to the next one I woke up I was
fine it was like a time zone [ __ ]
episode you guys this is [ __ ] crazy
ass party you met it I thought I partied
a little bit but um you made me excited
I'm like no partying Jesus Christ at 16
that's what I was doing
I was having my 15 and my mom dropped me
off at the mall a bottle of vodka and
quaaludes home and partying at that age
it was a safe that was a safe way across
the street from the park about a half a
mile from my school we had nothing to do
bro we could just walk in that Safeway
shoplift a bottle of booze and cross the
street and drink it the hell security
they thought I remember I had friends
who did that everyone like my boy Steve
been injured jacks some bottles of that
mad dog [ __ ] when we're young that's why
they have those stupid look caps now
that take 18 hours to take off of the
road well I did the worst I [ __ ] dry
house though Julio Rossi that [ __ ]
wine yeah that comes in what's the the
wine that comes in the gallon the box I
don't even like my now me and Louie cat
me neither dogs please me and Louis Katz
little tip oils big ol [ __ ] jugs with
the handle huh and we drank the whole
thing oh my god prefer God Jesus Christ
I had a headache for three [ __ ] eyes
and then you're throwing out man no I'm
not I'm not a drinker at all I can't
trust me neither I mean there's a point
where I like drink a little bit you know
a nice steak done just right with some
chili chili sauce
you know you dip stake in the trees I
love that that's so good I think in a
cold [ __ ] beer that would be nice
won't be just to have it yeah yeah sure
at that the one that's what I enjoy a
nice [ __ ] be a nice cold but like a
nice Asahi with some sushi no [ __ ] which
is something spicy or cuz why see
something something like alligators with
spicy
what I get when I get wings or something
like satyrs because I'm I like beers -
but sometimes beers can get bitter
so I'll get the [ __ ] wrong - don't
babies I would need them would win why
because then you're really a half a [ __ ]
don't you say these things you know
trying to break my heart
disagree with the beer and move on you
don't side with your wings and make it
look worse I always say you like my
wings even I get a [ __ ] x' and if I
do get insider to justify my existence
especially if it's medium or above
chases the cider when I went here a
couple weeks ago I went home and I was
showing the city Friday and I real
Friday I why I didn't want any drama so
I went to my neighborhood restaurant
Rudy's and I got these [ __ ] mussels
mmm first of all the gigantic they were
like a big fat [ __ ] click like if
she's 300 pounds what would it click
look that's what it was the more that's
the first thing that came here when you
saw daddy soon I just sucked them out
like this somebody's dead [ __ ] like
somebody left they click the sides again
now after this [ __ ] about a clam though
their muscles muscles they called
muscles and Rudy's makes this the best
ma you know Google muscles right now no
I'll show you the [ __ ] picture
there's not some type of plan look at
the foot look at the poopoo platter from
two weeks ago New York no Jersey oh my
God look at that [ __ ] dog ribs steak on
a stage now where do that skinny coach
you're gonna have the pool cleaner you
gotta have a plan man yeah well movie
chop digest all that we clean though we
chop down yeah we chop this up between
four of us someone really style what we
talking about we're talking about the
muscle the muscle let me show you the
most notorious I'm not really a big like
called uh he's chains you robbed our fan
so he can't eat for pump like a
[ __ ] but I don't like Bob are
you don't like what like the clams
mussels yeah I'm not Easter's in the
clamp oysters I dig clams and mussels
and clams on the half shell - I like
clam chowder
I don't like oysters that's the one that
Bob
voices are you never had an oyster
shooter no they make it out like a lot
of sushi restaurants pretty good I like
sushi I enjoy like that [ __ ] crab
when they [ __ ] get the crab and they
wrap it in the blue crab whatever I like
all that [ __ ] I like sushi I love it I
could eat that [ __ ] every [ __ ] day ask
the buyer but you go [ __ ] broke yeah
oh yeah it's expensive yeah I got I got
I got another loser watts look that's
the clam whether that's the mussels okay
see that's also because it has like all
that [ __ ] oh man yeah then that's that
[ __ ] that's sweet medium sauce mixed
together from Rudy's swing clear side
part look at the garlic cloves in there
you know what happens to your dick after
you eat that [ __ ] hold water Rudy's
muscles now you just get it look at the
shrimp a campy I love rising on those
places I was 17 okay over here look
everything [ __ ] over here really got a
mod this is [ __ ] and since I was 17 I
mean all the rules yeah and you when you
go meet um - that's not the that's Cuban
[ __ ] and that's it that's all I got cut
so that they can't be showing you my
whole food we gotta talk about health
and fitness
I wanna do I want can I ask a question
connects well you want I had a UH oh
yeah I was telling you before the
podcast I had like about a year where I
really [ __ ] up with my work once my
working out had my diet and out how much
could you you how long have you been
teaching matter like 15 years
what percentage of like like the success
of working out is mental mm or
percentage men see everybody's
everybody's different man you know some
people just have that thing where they
like routine and you know they get into
other people it takes a while man so
it's a lot of it is mental it could be
it just always said just varies from
person to person you know and to be
motivated to work out and stuff like
that you know and you have to do things
to to motivate yourself
I tell people like take a picture
yourself you know take a picture and
like you know like is that how you want
to look you want to look different you
know like use different motive ways to
motivate yourself you know right that's
true I mean and I just never like a lot
of women like they need a girl to a
girlfriend to come with them to motivate
then that motivates them because they're
doing it together maybe that you know
there's different ways to help motivate
yourself but like yeah the percentage
thing would have to vary from person to
president everybody's different men cuz
I was thinking about a conversation I
had with Joey when I was going to that
kettlebell place he was it kind of
expensive $110 a month uh-huh and he
said why don't you just get kettlebells
or why don't you do them at the gym like
white like you already know what you're
doing now and I think for some reason
with working out
I need a coach or a group because I'm
not good at just going just from us yeah
see that's different yeah for sure man
so then you're the type of person that
needs to go to some kind of boot camp or
something where there's somebody there
that's gonna make you do something
unless you want to hire a personal
trainer do it you know but I make me do
something but it like boys I like
motivate me and especially if I like if
I like the person I don't want to let
them down but not going yeah yeah yeah I
got you I got you got ya man you know
like you got to find something that
works for you and yeah it's not
everything it's really hard for a like a
lot of nuttin your average person can't
just go to the gym and stay motivated
work out by themselves right there are
some people that that are like that you
know but like it's a lot more fun to
training in a group though I think my
opinion I joined karate at the age of
five five or six what I really enjoy
about that day is that was the birth of
Joey karate right there we go do karate
my India Street West End guys still
alive then I cross the bridge when we
moved to Jersey and I joined bush and
real karate which it's all the same [ __ ]
in that time that time it's 1970 the
country was pretty much karate it was a
karate
called foo and judo were tied for second
in 1970 and nothing else
there was no savate there was no capo
whether there was
Brazilian Jujitsu not not back there was
there was a little Taekwondo Taekwondo
was making waves and different but not
as big as go Joo was the black karate
with the fist and then all the Vietnam
vets came back and they would teach in
their own style which was all the same
shear on Shotokan yokel King quick King
Kong there's all the [ __ ] sand and I
went to Guru karate but there was
something that happened I went the Guru
karate I was like 9 or 10 and I couldn't
wait to start lifting [ __ ] weight I
[ __ ] couldn't wait and my mom was not
going for it
I mean it was something that she was
like you have to wait till you're 14 you
know yourself and all this [ __ ] I would
go [ __ ] that so I would wait till she
was gone and I would take the closet the
sliding closets and I would unhinging
and put him on two chairs professor like
two [ __ ] barstools let me get a bench
press that's the ones with cement to
them yeah if you've dropped him too hard
there was shattered [ __ ] and I was bench
press and [ __ ] like I couldn't wait I
loved it I loved by the time I was 16 I
was on a regular weightlifting routine
not squats nothing but chest back yeah
yeah I used to be like that all guys I'd
love to like I didn't leave the house my
sophomore junior year till I worked out
seven o'clock
people came over and we all did we all
pushed each other and I loved it but
when I got into comedy that became my
love of obsession especially I got four
major legal to get in the major leagues
which is living in Los Angeles yeah and
your focus does shift you know and
there's a long for me right now it's a
mental thing for me it's I don't know
why I hate being overwhelmed with calmly
professor it [ __ ] drives me crazy if
all ten phone calls are about comedy it
drives me crazy then I had a right time
and I talked about counting
but the comics like I'm hanging out with
comics yeah so when I Oh jujitsu it's a
complete different mental game for me
yeah I talk to people while I'm a fat
[ __ ] in the back and I love that feeling
I love just being the fat [ __ ] in the
back we don't need to take pictures
we've talked about that hobby which is
your happy place
it's my happy since I've had a lot of
people coming in college and I think
that things I think that part of all
those years where I was [ __ ] up
professor was because I didn't have a
happy plan what hap you better have an
outlet man you making my same [ __ ]
always to the edge this was the problem
was I was a double agent
professor okay because I knew I had a
really interesting conversation Eddie
Bravo
and I know a couple interesting other
people think that I would even consider
it's [ __ ] hilarious Eddie Bravo asked
me something the other day I told him no
he almost died he goes so when you get
high before class how do you do cuz I
told that I called him I know I went
through Sundays ago not this last Sunday
the Sunday before I got murdered
professor Oh white belts were choking me
I I just didn't have it that day yeah
and I called Eddie I go if I ever
thought about quittin it would be there
was beat today
and he goes maybe he goes did you get
high before class I heard though I don't
get high before class I go if I got a 12
o'clock class the last time I'll get
highs at 8:30 I won't get I three hours
before [ __ ] and he's like get the [ __ ]
out of him like you think I'm [ __ ]
with you I got you dead though no I
always thought you did like oh no
no not this last time but my six months
ago one night I went to the we'd start
to when the afternoon and I bought we
then they gave me a hundred milligram
retreat do you know what I do it oh my
god no I do you know that does to me we
ate uh what time I wait like five
hundred tonight and look at me look at
500 hundred milligram does to me nothing
hmm I ate it didn't even think about it
I didn't think I'm it didn't even haunt
me till I was walking up the corner Oh
God as I'm walking up the corner um I
might be making a mistake
I saw Burroughs wife remember walking in
and having to sit down and people wanted
to shake my hand and hug me and I'm
trying to fake the funk yeah yeah yeah
at that point I would just go backward I
think I'll get another ball you I ran I
got my I came back in this other guy at
night you can't go in the back of the
jump injection and warm up a little bit
back so I had to go right on the mat and
during the war huh when you do the the
grip crisis oh I think that over the
crows show chunkies the [ __ ] the
cross let me tell you sell its cause
Charlie anxiety was off the chart and
I'm looking at you and you don't know
what's going on and I'm hi oh my god and
I and then we went over a technique and
we did the technique and that was cool
in the first role the wipeout mounted me
and I was like out of breath I'm sitting
there ready to die and who do I spot a
blue belt that's a woman I go that's my
next victim and I just got on top of
that was it until you like my class is
over and I'm like it all broke so
creeped up that you know what six hours
later I forgot about the [ __ ] thing
that's crazy
until your heart start
be late reaction but it happens with
calmly - like sometimes you may be able
to three go out to dinner
ah-ha-ha-ha and once you go on stage the
adrenaline level goes up the lights its
lights in everything kicks in now so you
ain't yeah ya know but it's not bro I
think I think being underneath a guy
like you and half guard there's more
scarier than me than being on Slade's
bomber at the 10-minute mark you have no
idea when you bomb dog and calmly you
have to the best is when you open for
somebody and you bomb my fee is eye open
for Rogan and bombed huh and when people
come on go Joe you were great and also
they look at you they go you look good
too you sucked you have to walk out and
photos welcome people like that is I
can't imagine that's crazy around
horrible horrible feeling
yeah people's careers have ended when
they have and you make these videos and
you're putting natural in front of a
camera I've been doing it for a while
they look for well but I think I'm my
natural actor are you so if anybody's
giving any roles out there they'll give
somebody you know you mean I don't have
a chance of being discovered on air
anybody if Harvey was still around a big
balls man get you up to the hotel you
could teach in jiu-jitsu in a ballerina
suit oh my god so next thing you know
we're gonna have like chicks in there
from the rap video of saying hey man
Snoop Dogg will esta me or some [ __ ]
like that so he already admitted to
being a pimp so I feel like no but like
roxana's decision who Snoop Dogg
represent all the girls in the video
although you kidding well those girls
used to go to those parties and get the
[ __ ] off for sure do not gang rape the
word is in gang no but willing they'll
get willingly doing my thing willingly
map because like that like for sure man
I remember own yeah okay as some of
those I'm something he I think he did it
but I don't think you took the money or
something it's a rolling stone article
from 2013 in oh three you put an
organization together yeah when he was
doing the playboy tour he had bus fall
with ten [ __ ] on I could fire [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you get a new ho he
said see the city - oh my god I'll put
this up there I guess for you but yeah
oh but yeah but he I'm like he'd take
her money but he'd give the money back
to her so he's just pretending if you
just wanted to see what it was like oh
my god
so people do that are millionaires you
know they just hang out but pretend to
be a pimp for a little while just to see
what it's like bunny oh that the Bunny
Wailer is a he's a pimp was he a pimp
who's Bunny Wailer oh I'd see that I'd
like him to take the money from the
wedding chuckles so how's this going
goes wife it was survival hey my wife
had to take a backseat to this [ __ ] I
love it
Thursday because she could've [ __ ] got a
[ __ ] but she stayed in my corner
haha well I decided to let go she was
still there yeah you look at man 10
right there says a lot of athletes but
[ __ ] from was like city-to-city titty
titty hotel no tell him I mean what
listen you know you Justin Bieber you
know you're on a tour bus
bitching Jackman's you know he was
telling me a story years ago about when
Paulie sure was at his peak then he got
to his club at the time he goes I was
like a server but I remember coming in
and seeing a whiny girls and it was
Pauly in the bus was blind like things
and he had a guy outside waiting to and
he would have get girls that would just
come in to suck his dick yeah yeah
I'm gonna put yourself in that type
position that's your [ __ ] business
she hasn't fallen short so justin bieber
man i can't you know I can't imagine
what who's going into that's crazy
what what yeah you got nothing going on
you live here you're hot you got a hot
body you wear those [ __ ] hot [ __ ]
shoes well I'm gonna tell you haveno you
take some lay on the road I had a know
the [ __ ] knows man you just try to do
the best you can and try to be a
gentleman but on those road things you
saw what fresh outta compton when they
[ __ ] the fresh i happen whatever the
[ __ ] the movie is the hip they had eight
chicks in the room the black guy knocked
on the door and she was sucking the
guy's dick and that's his girlfriend but
isn't the point until I get someone new
one in every city water they want to
take somebody that's maybe there's
different that's what a group he is man
that's what I'm sorry you bring rubies
on the road groupies follow the rookie
follows bands and okay this is gonna
drive themselves and that's okay
sometimes I get like a pair what was
that movie they make this is full of
them now remember that movie they did
with the front with uh with the guy from
My Name Is Earl and Mark Marin about
music really good music almost an almost
famous almost famous a while it was
almost famous so the other one rock star
it was rock star rock star where the
girls follow in the back girlfriends
were in the back yeah or something like
that yeah
those guys had weird [ __ ] rules on
tours Bravo's that those are tours with
twenty people on him late holy [ __ ]
that's our money but your dealer your
coke dealer your [ __ ] weed dealer
your psychic healer you know your your
relationship they still charge you for
the weed it's listen who the [ __ ] knows
Lee you're making millions of dollars
you were living in a [ __ ] camp and
next thing you know you're selling out
arenas you don't even know how much
money you [ __ ] have you have the
number one album in the [ __ ] country
and five nights a week you're selling
out nineteen thousand [ __ ] seats two
shows a [ __ ] night
what do you think happens in the
seventies and eighties when the music
business drugs and rock'n'roll was still
alive when music was still alive and you
put out an outline you sold 10 billion
[ __ ] copies like we don't Whitney
Houston numbers and you know what's the
chick that sang the Titanic
so Indian you know those numbers that
that takes you into millions of millions
of dollars crazy how much money music
music has millions of layers to it you
know Rob Thomas I read a story one time
a Rob Thomas how much he made of writing
one [ __ ] song I was he always kept
the rights who the [ __ ] knows a lot of
ones I have a [ __ ] maid yeah man you
know mazing look at look at what look at
the controversy that happened with the
Beatles and Michael Jackson Michael
Jackson bought the rights to the Beatles
music hunt the [ __ ] Paul McCartney's
knows why do you think he bought that
because there was so much that means any
time [ __ ] Chevrolet wants to use
whatever song he's gonna be making money
few girly units that that's gonna be the
honey big The Beatles catalogue is he
[ __ ] crazy even Led Zeppelin broke
down Led Zeppelin who will the kings of
anti-commercial
once they weren't we Cadillac but I
guarantee you Cadillac has a Bey's Epple
a lot of [ __ ] money Don yeah I
guarantee one of those guys felt raised
and said listen my bank account felling
the two hundred million for the first
time in 20 years
music business is huge man I was just
watching that the Joe Rogan when he had
Billy Corgan on there and I mean not the
smash brothers they're pretty big but I
didn't realize they made that much money
oh [ __ ] yeah he was talking about like
going and just for the hell of it just
go walking and buy a [ __ ] Ferrari or
Lamborghini she was like wow because I
remember they that one album a Siamese
Dream was huge and after that they had
another one was pretty big but like men
like I mean when you're selling a couple
million albums
I guess you're making it a shitload of
cheddar if you haven't taken the road
for a year you performed four nights a
week
like with Guns and Roses just it yeah
right now they then
taking the toy distended Wednesday that
it was uh they did it alive on whatever
the [ __ ] it was but I can't imagine with
the money they made they brought it home
and shed a little money that's because
the fed up to get back together they had
a promised them a big amount of money
that's a without for sure for sure for
sure
listen the money's there you know they
were gettin they might show they were
getting two thousand dollars a ticket
but there's Wednesday night Wow cuz that
was the last night of the tour at the
[ __ ] for no it stuns them that was
very how this you drive down Sunset
there's no more record stores there's
none of the ones over by nobody buys
nonetheless crazy how that you know
changed you know I haven't been living
to walk into a [ __ ] like the other
hand when I went to the one by Burbank
that's one of my favorite ones which one
what I'm too lazy to drive to Hollywood
to amoeba which I need to go they've
been in the music store and God knows oh
Jesus Christ
this I just buy everything on google
play man I don't care remember the last
time I bought a CD or a DVD for that
matter let me tell you some you have to
go told me but I just one time yeah me I
mean that's just to walk around I love
it I don't know me but I walk around I
see the music I remember [ __ ] yeah
because you forget a ton of [ __ ] - I
forgotten more about music than most
people I believe it because I went
through twenty three thousand phases of
music
same here you know from the pretenders
to I went through so many different
genres that I forgot about some [ __ ] I
like this rashing Punk that's more I
never saw them live yeah I like them too
I mean now like I like the album before
the Sun Room and Siamese Dream and then
I kind of got out of them for a little
while but I was around like the whole
grunge era yeah I didn't realize that
they made that much risk or no
which was one of the reasons why you
wanted to come on here I forgot yes
we're supposed to be loving a lot Chris
Cornell can you imagine how much Gita's
he's gonna get the next couple years
oh man now he's low salt oh yeah yeah
yeah that's where the dough is right
when you're the rider then you make the
majority of the cut so he wrote the Sam
garden yeah he wrote for his songs all
that and that's that's initially I think
that's what broke up
Audioslave was it I think so because I
think it was like he was like I was he
was supposed to get the bigger cut and
it caused a little you know something
some and then that's what I that's where
I had read I don't know if it's a
hundred percent true crazy about two
weeks ago I was driving like a while I
haven't heard Chris Cornell music on the
radio in a few months you know just
people just must have got together so
let's give it a break when I get in the
car do the morning and rusty cages on
and I think another four or five yet
they fell on black days oh my [ __ ] how
good was this [ __ ] hell yeah man like I
kind of like couldn't listen to it for a
little while you know I mean I recently
started playing some like temple the dog
and some some Soundgarden stuff like
that but man I just just thinking about
it would make me sad just make me sad
over it Wow Chris Cornell's really done
it special sex you know that she has
been weird
this year was a weird year but the music
industry took a heavy hit this year how
many [ __ ] people died Prince David
Bowie Chester Bennington Chris Cornell
Who am I missing there's somebody a few
a few other people without us we lost my
brother Ralphie made this year after me
it's been starting to bother me the last
three Saturdays this morning I woke up I
think that's why I went back to bed this
morning because I got too depressed
about it because he would call me on
Saturday morning if he knew I was off
the road and he knows that no matter
what time I go to sleep Friday I always
get up for Ag Saturday morning I get
stoned I watch something bad
now like for a while I'm like he's just
on the road in your mind you like he's
just on the road but now that I'm not
hearing and there's somebody posted a
picture the other day on Twitter of them
would have had a you know and then from
time to time his [ __ ] page comes up
and just you know he had a Twitter page
that said tour dates and a picture him
going or whatever with tour dates and
for some reason I don't think him glad
we're ever friends on Twitter haha sorry
keep saying friend them and so it's
[ __ ] up like you'd gonna I can't
believe I'm never gonna see that guy
yeah man he's never gonna screws and
sherry look yeah I've been Fran I've
been there just too many times so know
how you feel the same way it was like
the first my first year teaching at
Legacy I lost three students from my old
gym the first one was my boy Eldon
Navarro like once I started she she had
legacy some of my students started
coming out there I never asked him to
come but they're like hey you're there
is it cool for going right oh yeah
that's cool you know and little by
little my former students from Earl
Jones SoCal started showing up you know
and we're all training and Eldon walks
in and we're like eleda no [ __ ] you know
we're like happy to see him he signed up
literally no [ __ ] joyed the next day he
jumps on the 5 on his motorcycle
it's ran over and dies and you just and
you know like what happens is like these
memories palpable in facebook too and
you're like [ __ ] man that's [ __ ]
that's crazy dude you know like I mean
he was young man you know it's [ __ ] up
dude I had another student
yanny she died in a [ __ ] mountain
biking accident like a few months later
dude
crazy dude like I would never realized
mountain biking was out dangerous I
thought they'd just [ __ ] mountain
bikes through the woods and [ __ ] like
jumped over logs and stuff but
apparently they do like crazy [ __ ] like
driving on the edge of [ __ ] mountains
and shouldn't I don't know what she did
but she flew off and then I guess she
hit her head and went into a coma and
and she was just brain-dead so they had
to pull the plug
no Yandy she was like in her 30s then I
had another another one um John heads
gold like he he killed himself and [ __ ]
man
you know and it's [ __ ] crazy man you
know it's crazy man people just dropping
off flies man you know that and that's
kind of like been my story my whole life
I was like had a lot of people died in
me man so no it's really meant I was
raised Emmanuel is you and I remember my
uncle telling me one day goes me home he
goes he goes just he goes don't think
it's God punishing you man he was like
he's like sometimes people some people
get it worse than others you know
because my mom died my dad died my
little brother was strangled three years
ago crazy [ __ ] man
it's crazy so it makes you it really
makes you appreciate life a lot more
than this you're getting it yeah you got
appreciate everything that you have no I
always I lost the friends and the
parents an early age and now it hits me
differently now I know how to cope oh
yeah everybody'll know that did a
Ralphie thing you know that's why I tell
people it's a process when the grieving
process it's a long process yeah and it
could either be a long one or a short
one it all depends like some people the
first holiday is tough one yeah you know
I always did something with Ralphie
around yeah exactly I giving the holiday
is the last time he is he was married he
had kids you know he was a natural I
love to see him I can sit here and tell
you all know that I wasn't like that but
we talk you know these are your comedy
friends these are people that you grew
with you know you want standout role as
they watch you grow it's a special type
of bond you know so no the Cornell thing
and look I heard and I thought I said to
myself I hadn't heard it and boom I
heard two [ __ ] jams and now I'm back
and now it's the [ __ ] month when you
hear these [ __ ] things under the year
and all the people we lost this year
yeah yeah yeah and all that [ __ ] yep but
anyway the other reason why we talked I
know you have another video coming out
mhm
what is this coming out and what's the
name of this well I'm working on the KB
flow 90-day challenge we already filmed
like eight weeks of it so got a little
bit more filming to go but it should be
out like in the new year like January
like maybe late January or so but it's
in the works so get the KB flow programs
right now like that's kind of like a
trend with kettlebells you know there
everybody's doing kettlebell flows and
stuff like that and um everybody sees my
videos and they see other people doing
it but that's kind of kind of originally
when I started doing I developed
kettlebell flows because I was born with
basically subscriber to flow is for me
like and it berries you know people have
their own version of what they think of
flow is but you know I I started doing
kettlebell close for a reason because my
whole idea was trying to always trying
to make kettlebell training closer to
jiu-jitsu so in jiu-jitsu and it comes
to jiu-jitsu using all your muscles that
all the time together you know so you're
pushing you're pulling you're hinging
and you're squatting in some way some
some form another when you're doing
jiu-jitsu so a kettlebell foe for me is
putting multiple movements together and
combining those together into one
continuous flow where you're working
your whole body like some people like
say maybe you say like Professor I do
five of those things right here I do
five cleans right here
that wouldn't be a flow that's more like
a ladder you're doing everything but
like for me like doing a flow today we
did squat curl press squat curl press
figure eight till holes figure eight
till hold rocket clean it squat curl
press squat you don't understand figure
eight to a hole so that's like a flow
you know so like when you combine
multiple large muscle groups together
then your heart rate shoots up that's
why Jesus is so hard you're using all
your muscles you're harvested subs
you're sweating start breeding having
you're burning calories so and in
addition to that like a lot of people
don't realize like when you're training
jiu-jitsu the muscle guess what the
muscle is that you're working the most
you're because you're no matter what
you're you're pretty much always using
your this muscle whatever your heart or
your hip says the heart is a muscle too
but your forearms man you got to think
about you're all were always [ __ ] guy
I thought those are the grab and grab
and grab and grab and grab they did a
study on it like my little boy Benny
speaking of Benny a bunny-bot Cobra he's
always like looking [ __ ] up and sending
me stuff professor look this is the
number one word just like you say goes
the kettlebell flows because with a
kettle flow you're not putting that Bell
down for like an extended period of time
like maybe like almost two minutes so
your forearms are blowing up as well as
kind of are using today I use like a 20
kilogram kettle going on if you guys
look at the kettlebell flows on my
Instagram right now
not easy guys it's like 42 pounds yeah I
mean I don't really consider it that
heavy you know like there's some people
I know a girl shout out to my girl
Brittany k be fit Brit she does a sport
kettlebell lifting and she does to 24
kilograms long cycles that means ten
minutes of particular exercise for ten
minutes straight I've seen those things
where they do like hundreds of swings or
hundreds of clea yeah yeah I thought
users cry like people do that and you
know I'm not really the biggest fan of
it because it's just like why do you
need to do a thousand repetitions of any
particular exercise I really you get
that but you know people like use that
as a different way to motivate
themselves you know I mean like oh I got
to do it now the challenge I'm gonna try
to do a thousand swings this week you
know just something people like to set
goals you know you know I'm not a fan of
the thousand swings because I mean like
it's kind of like overworking your the
posterior chamber a little bit but what
I've hundred swings is but a better goal
I don't even man honestly after a week
we don't even get a hundred we don't
even get a hundred swings in usually
yeah it's not about like how many it's
about the whole routine together and
work in all your muscles evenly you know
I don't like working one muscle more
than another you know I like to get a
full body workout
like if after you leave like one of my
kids doesn't workouts are gonna fill it
everywhere gonna fill it everywhere not
going to just fill it in your butt or
your legs or your chest whatever you I
mean that's what I'm always trying
trying to accomplish in the workout is
to get a full body workout and a safe
workout so the KB flow challenge is
gonna have basically like what people
see on my Instagram they see one minute
of a workout they're not seeing what
leads up to that you only mean so like
something that you have to break each
flow down little by little step by step
and drill it with the kettlebell and
then you leads up to the kettlebell flow
so on this on this program that I'm
doing it's gonna teach is gonna teach
you how to structure flows and how to
warm up properly and everything like
that and it's going to be in levels so
by by the end of the the 90-day program
man you're going to have like a really
amazing understanding of kettlebells and
not only just get a little bit like
movement with kettlebells because that's
why I love kettlebells so much because
you can add someone
movement to it as well you know but it
doesn't get too crazy you know like
nowadays people are really into doing
the most complicated flow as possible
but the way I look at it is like it's
not really practical I wouldn't be able
to teach it to a class anyway you have
to make the flows practical so people
can actually do them with you as well
you know but you know that's the beauty
of fitness man you can just do whatever
you want you know you could do crazy
flows or I'm always thinking about how
am I going to teach this to my students
as well you know so like the KB flow
program that's going to be coming out
it's going to have it's gonna be
structured like from the beginning
kettle bell flow to intermediate to
advanced to like double kettle bell
flows and stuff like that as well
so finding that program you're gonna be
a kettle bell beast for shell let me ask
you this lightly that's it this is the
month where people still look at
themselves and go I bought these pants
and they [ __ ] don't fit no more my
wife is [ __ ] putting them in this
ring this is the one month where people
don't work out man the gym gets slow all
the time this time but yeah and they're
just they're just waiting for the final
to be hacked and then then yeah new year
that's when the new year's resolutions
kick in and then everybody wants to
[ __ ] work out again you know it's and
then summer comes around and it slows
down again they're like Oh some guy 40
typical forties used to work out stop
because he had a kid or something he
starts watching one of your videos
what's the first video I think you know
because yet some great videos out of
that like you got like that three minute
intervals you got [ __ ] the free
workout sample the basic tutorial you
got some great little you even had a
piece that was in jiu-jitsu magazine
yeah yeah as you can see magazine a
couple of times yeah what can they start
off it just you know honestly what's
like um man you know you have to find
kettlebells it's not something that or
just exercise in general is just
something you just don't want to look at
Instagram and just grab something start
don't you have a program online yeah
yeah I mean you can go on ma online any
of my programs start from absolute
beginner so like anybody could pick up
anyone in my program so I'm not gonna
just I haven't thrown just like a
straight advanced workout out there you
know
so like all my programs if you go on
online and actually you know what like I
forgot to take everything down from my
Black Friday sale so everything's still
discounted right now so it's super cheap
you can get $9.99 you can get a
one-month Turkish get a program right
now
and it's gonna take you step-by-step
from beginner to advanced you know so
like anybody can pick up one of my
downloads and and start from scratch I
definitely do not recommend like looking
at an Instagram video and be like hey
and just pick up a kettlebell and start
doing it because like I said there's a
lot that leads up to it you know you
have to know how to warm up properly and
stuff like that so like my downloads is
just like basically like having me in
your living room to work out with you
know and that's how I try to make them
so I watch i watch it you won't find a
place that has a legit kettlebell person
and learn from them
it's funny because I know you start to
certify people I've been certifying
people for a little longer and they're
all over the country yep all over the
world and but surely I see the people
who just basically work with you huh and
I've seen how they've transformed
especially how the jujitsu game the one
killer works is dads mechanic shop you
boy in the morning but to the Filipino
kid the doctor that came from very Mac
will all miss Marquart Carvalho I see
how they Gaines all change huh you teach
a different type of game jiu-jitsu yeah
that's really I could see it with the
people that you work with you know a
sure man you no shame I can't get up a
sixth mmm cease not for everybody man
but yeah I have a but I think I have a
particular style you know I kind of like
try to emulate my master Hodgman
Machado's style of jiu-jitsu you know
like I really he really just emphasizes
like technique over strength and not
hurting people and just flow that's
almost talked about flow you always hear
me saying be like water be like water be
like water like that's how I like to try
to try to roll like in the tournament
it's totally different it's a lot harder
it's a lot crazier but like yeah a lot
of my guy the guys had a train over
there we try to get him that that nice
flowy style you know transition and
stuff like that your beautiful [ __ ]
man let me do some shout outs here yeah
the polarizer were a new podcast
man Chris Hardy peep an odd Oh Alexander
Voight Rocky rebellion Sam Firmino Chris
hado dawn Wrangler and my main man the
Australian warrior and Dante the email
Kazemi you know saying I love the death
he's a [ __ ] Savage don't forget
tonight I'm gonna be Observatory in San
Diego I'll be leaving here after I
[ __ ] get out of here so I'll see you
[ __ ] tonight and tomorrow night
I'm in the Santa Ana Observatory with my
main man
we will walk a journey at both nights
[ __ ] Sunday night was [ __ ]
tremendously was dancing some country
girl one of those like is nuts
it was my coffee Wolf's theme backwards
thank you for good thank you for having
me yeah well it's gonna be [ __ ] great
it's gonna be great I don't know it was
great last night I can't see being any
better tonight always a [ __ ] pleasure
seeing you professor thanks for having
me on again Joe I appreciate it people
like people have been hitting me up when
you be on the show again
yeah I love you that's cool man I took a
nice picture yesterday I'm gonna go to
class tomorrow all right
because Monday I can't go to class home
today I got you up I'm gonna drive to
Sandy him saying try to forget you my
god you seen you up in there you know I
love you number one remember one thing I
told you christmas is coming who the
[ __ ] needs socks who the [ __ ] wants this
who the [ __ ] wants anything they don't
want dick you know what they want they
want to get their balls lick and their
dicks up and to do that that area has to
be clean
that's why hello - she is changing lives
you understand me
you sitting there going watch how old is
she it's a portable bidet you adjust in
your toilet and after you take the [ __ ]
of life you press a button and a stream
of fountain water cleans you [ __ ] all
that fungi and leftover chicken wings
and whatever else the [ __ ] you been
eating so when you're writing your
Christmas list the sound of this
tell that son of a [ __ ] he still owes
you Gators and all you want is a clean
butt cheeks that's it and we got access
to pinecones
who needs [ __ ] dingleberries dignify
your bowels
I'll go holy and some fuzzy pudding
smeared all over your [ __ ] Christmas
night unholy night you need touchy
that's who you need a nice cushy
birthday chestnuts roasting on an open
fire
and your [ __ ] is as clean as a
[ __ ] nuns monkey you follow me
it's cleans you ass better than any
toilet paper on the market and it uses
clean water to spray your butt providing
you with a shower of fresh feeling after
every [ __ ] understand me where'd you get
that from then don't worry about what we
get enough done done don't be asking
questions it's all about how old 30
that's what it's all about between a
song I want and having a portable
birthday I want well if you want one
this is always gonna work out all right
they come in a millennial pink and blue
to add to a proper culture to your
bathroom they even have two models with
fancy bamboo knobs and they start at $69
they got new colors and this is what
people want stop [ __ ] around with
worthless [ __ ] Christmas present make
sure your friend has a clean [ __ ] how
much you're giving keeps giving every
time every time your friend goes home
and takes a [ __ ] pushes that button
button he's gonna think he he's gonna
say that [ __ ] knows that I give
a present I'm gonna have him over I
wanna have my next Christmas party well
if you want what you got doing people is
I want to think of you right after I
take it down you guys gonna hello Lucy
calm right now and what we're gonna do
is we're gonna give you a bidet portable
beautiful they start at $69 with a
risk-free 60 day trial now Lee has not
busted his bidet he's got a big ass and
I haven't busted mine
Thompson girl hasn't [ __ ] this up
which means the quality on these things
is fantastic stop walking around with
cracking jokes hearing [ __ ]
right now you're sitting there do
yourself a favor look around when
nobody's watching stick your finger up
yes sniffing is that what you need in
your life go to hell - [ __ ] calm right
now and press in church and get 10% off
your just gave him a new catchphrase I
don't [ __ ] around
yeah number two on ted.com supplements
you want to be healthy
listen I can't get you any points off on
the steel bells or the kettle bells but
as far as alpha brain um ahem fours
protein the acai vanilla which you love
my professors like that one in a locker
and the coton of the coco coco loco Coco
let's see how for brain the mocha Coco
hemp horse and shroom tech sport are my
favorites why [ __ ] around go down and
calm right now press in church BAM 10%
off delivered right to your house nobody
gets their feelings hurt number three
you're gonna shop for a new key your
girlfriend listen go to fuji between the
elemental the sakai which means world in
japanese if you didn't know that
and the Saporito their tremendous tree
gauge and the stand and separate I mean
it's a burrito means mind your [ __ ]
business questions that's a slippery no
means in Japanese all right so the
Saporito the Sakai and the [ __ ] the
elemental are tremendous keys and all of
them a lightweight it doesn't for you
get a bulletproof [ __ ] jacket on you
when you're trying to when people trying
to choke it's bad enough it's hot in
there and these [ __ ] Brazilians don't
turn the egg anyway I love my men
Joey Alvarado professor joy but what's
the website they go they're just gonna
Google kettle jitsu don't forget always
when you're getting kettle bells also
look at these people - kettle bell Kings
they supply kettle bells my spots for
cannabis crossings and give them a
little holla holla won't get mad we're
all family it wall chase the same nickel
so Oh
December's here you got [ __ ] 21 days
of shoplifting left cops up this get
ready we'll see you later this week we
never play let's just close the Tony but
it tonight
you [ __ ] up tonight Lee that's how
high I got that
pull out Tony Bennett I love you guys
see you Wednesday see you tonight in San
Diego stay black peace out
[Music]